normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
the hill Trump says he'd consider Tucker
Carlson as running mate quote I like
Tucker a lot I guess I would Trump said
during an appearance on the Klay Travis
and buck seon show this week I think I'd
say I would because he's got great
common sense you know when they when
they say that you guys are conservative
or I'm conservative it's not that we're
conservative we have common sense we
have to have safe borders we want to
have a wall because walls work Carlson
was fired by Fox News blah blah blah
there you go it's uh it's not a very big
uh a very verbose story but there is uh
there's one legitimate reason why we
talk about something like this is
because no one really no one really has
a good guess as to who Trump's VP is
actually going to be and I get to ask
this quite a bit I thought Carrie Lake
would be good but she's she's running
for Senate in Arizona which makes a lot
of sense and I think that's that's a
better use of for time you know honestly
and uh some people are saying the ramas
Swami especially with how well he did
last night but there's one other reason
why this is our lead story I'm trying to
Manifest this like I personally would
love a trump Carlson take it because uh
uh what we often say is Trump needs that
like San rational calmer person and I
think uh you know a lot of people
thought it would be disantis not
DeSantis Tucker Carlson is is massive
and I I think he could he could push
Trump over the over the limit there's no
beating that ticket did Trump say he was
going to pick a woman like a few months
ago no there's just a rumor about it all
time I thought I thought Tulsi was going
to be on the ticket not a Supreme Court
vote so it doesn't have to be a woman
and it's not it's not they're not w i
mean what's Trump who's Trump trying to
uh uh validate what's he trying to prove
I know I I thought because I thought
Carrie was going to be it until she
announced to run for Senate and then
tulsy said she was willing to work with
Trump toy has said stuff I mean Christy
NM has positioned TR there's a couple
different people who are vying for the
spot obviously my thing is if Tucker
becomes the VP that could be fun but I
want him to keep his Twitter show right
like the things that we love about
Tucker Carlson exist because they are
outside of politics in the government
and I wouldn't want to lose that and
it's a question of too like how much
money is Tucker losing by trying to be
VP for Trump right this is a this is a
big challenge you have to really want it
VI he's worth what 600 something million
dollars so I I got to be honest I'm I'm
sure V got to a certain point where he's
like I can't buy anything anymore like
what do I want and he's like well maybe
like one thing you can't buy technically
is a high ranking government position
although let's be real there's a certain
level where it's all for sale and then
there's a certain level where it's not
you know like being VP or president is
something you can only you can buy a
little bit of but you really got to push
the rest and then you've got to
basically sell promises to a bunch of
evil people but if you want to be an
ambassador a that's a cash deal after
the way he talked to the moderator last
night I was like he'd be a great press
secretary a lot of people are saying
that yeah but I don't think he'd want to
be press secretary I mean the thing that
I like about V is that he feels like he
wants to be in charge of something and I
think that's cool that he wants to sort
of contribute in that way I mean V V's
not my choice president although I
admire him a lot he's great uh I have
some I would want him to be stronger on
restricting legal immigration I've said
that a mil times everyone's bored of
this comment but it is fun to see him
out there right he is shaking up
Politics the way that I think the same
way we feel at Tucker Carlson vice
presidency would shake up this
established thing we're sort of like
let's hearken back to Mike Pence and
this is not to be directly mean to him
but he just sort of faded into the
background and we were like yes that
that one white Evangelical from the
Midwest he he wasn't anything until the
end when he was a big problem right uh
and I think we would expect more from A
A A Carlson vice presidency well I do
think considering we're we're in a wacky
simulation that doesn't seem to make
sense at all you're going to have to
think crazier in terms of VP pick right
Kanye West you know go forward that waso
yeah it was Trum Trump West was floated
around Kanye on true social I think
wrote a thing saying I will let Trump be
my VP right I'm sure Trump was like
thank you so much very gracious of him
yeah I mean I think the other thing is
that we are seeing people who are at the
front like in some ways I do think
running for president for a lot of
people is just to raise your National
profile so realistically the people who
are creating the short list of potential
VP candidates are looking beyond the
people were appearing appearing on the
debate stage I mean Biden picked off the
debate stage Cala dropped out then she
got her facelift it was obvious she was
going to be VP these are historical
facts why you laughing at me but you
know with a lot of presence in the past
it's a I mean who had heard of Sarah
Palin really before she got tapped to
bvp there are people that were're not
aware of and I wouldn't be surprised if
Trump's team is expanding Beyond people
who hold government positions right yeah
but I mean who's it like the the the
goal of the VP is to capture the
demographic that the the
the candidate doesn't capture and so I
think this is what uh who who was saying
this was it uh was it Robbie maybe
Robbie Starbuck I'm not sure they said
what demographic does a capture that's
he's he's he's basically got Trump
voters already you know that's this is
the funny thing he says all the perfect
things that every Trump voter wants to
hear and they're going to smile as they
vote for Trump and say oh hey VI and
they're going to hit Trump exactly so
he's got to like if even if he was going
to be the VP is he gaining anything for
that ticket right that was the argument
with Mike Pence that he gave him he gave
Trump Evangelical voters in the midwest
he locked that down but I don't know if
that's I think that's why people want
there's this ongoing thing that it'll
definitely be a woman because you know
it was like Suburban women are the ones
who pulled away from Trump the most so
theoretically if he put a lady in the VP
office you know that will maybe win them
back I don't think that's actually true
I just think that's like a because then
who's it going to be like Christine and
maybe but they're going to push Nikki
Haley that's exactly what I was thinking
as well has history with Trump already
right she worked in the Trump
Administration absolutely I think the
relationship's too contentious I don't
think he would take Nikki Haley yeah but
look at look at the the GOP debates in
2016 and you know what I mean like it
was contentious and then everyone got
past it this this always happens Cala
called you know Biden a
racist right that she like no work
politics yeah right I think uh there's a
lot of women who are disaffected
liberals who like RFK and that maybe
there's an RFK Trump thing happening
down the ticket is perhaps yeah you know
I mean I also think that we look down to
like a attorney general levels like
Chris kobach from Kansas like there are
other people who have interesting points
I mean the thing that rally Trump voters
in my opinion back in 2016 really was
the wall in Immigration that set him in
a lot of ways he was already different
from a lot of candidates but when he
said I'm going to build the wall that
was something a lot of people rallied
around so to pick someone female male
whatever who is taking a strong stance
of immigration would in some ways
reignite the base and we know that the
the immigration crisis the border is
something that is starting to be a
conversation in more moderate and left
leaning spheres progresses will probably
never vote for anyone who would build a
wall but there are other people who are
feeling the burdens that might come
Adams want I'm feeling worried it's
going to be Nikki Haley's VP cuz people
have have floated that before and every
everyone everyone in the room just shook
their head Nikki Haley is John McCain's
skeleton in a wig like we can't have her
anywhere near the White House and that
and that performance last night was
terrible I can't see her not according
to the New York Times well they see and
the New York Times definitely knows how
Republican votes movies
now one of the other big stories we got
is uh CNN New York Times AP and reuter
journalists embedded with Hamas going to
the attack on Israel so it's like they
knew but uh right right now a bunch of
media workers are protesting the New
York Times because they're not favorable
to they say Palestine but we know what
they mean by that so that just helps you
understand the kind of people who work
for the New York Times yep yep yeah yeah
it's interesting I said this morning
Nikki haly was so excited to go to war
that she preure bombed on stage last
night that's a good one I just still
can't get over her heel tweet being like
I wear them it doesn't make any sense
it's so annoying she said I wear heels
for ammunition what does that her heels
are ammunition she's giving women a bad
name everywhere it makes you never want
to wear heels again be associated with
that comment Pelosi said she would use
her heels to stab the uh Riders she had
an interview she talked about that she
would have taken off her heels and stab
people with that's what Nikki was
referencing probably is that what she's
CL she uses she said I wear heels but
they're not for fashion they're for
ammunition but then I saw that video of
like a reporter throwing a shoe at Bush
I was like oh yeah yeah oh man I I I
remember when that happened the the shoe
throw ah those are the
days so
old and then you see like Secret Service
busting into the back like 5 minutes
late to be honest like it was a it was
not their best moment I mean maybe
that's what she meant maybe she was just
preparing to throw her shoes across
cross it V she was pretty angry at him
Bush can dodge shoes and questions about
why he went to war for 20 years yeah
yeah and the left has accepted him back
into like the good graces yeah he threw
the opening pitch recently yeah Kimel
had him on like a year or two to talk
about his paintings this is the thing so
I went to Southern M University in
Dallas and he his Presidential Library
is on that campus and I had a a liberal
Professor tell me at one point she's
like nowhere in America is he more
popular than at this campus CU he would
come to like our basketball games we
chant USA and like it's not you like
this politics but it's like this is kind
of hilarious we have a president who
just sits in all of he like would
randomly show up in class wow I do need
to point out though when VI said Dick
Cheney and threein heels the moderator
cut him off but he does say and we've
got two of them on stage tonight yeah
that actually sliced the joke so
everyone immediately like I tweeted I
was like wow he called Nikki Haley Dick
Cheney and some people were like I think
he's talking about Ron and then I played
the CP back and he literally says and we
have two of them he was talking about
both of them but the moderator cut him
off the bouet thing to me is so silly
like we're a bunch of grown men talking
about other men's feet like is this
politics now this this is the important
thing matter I've heard the the argument
about you know integrity and honesty and
you should be honest about yourself and
if you you have to wear you know lifts
if it was some type of decision made by
your team to be youo taller than you
said yes to it well maybe you shouldn't
have said yes to that I think it's
because you can't take a joke I don't
care how tall you are it's just like
that him or the team can't take J show
insecurity and it also shows who who
staff himself with right like again I
thought D Sanz would have been a good VP
pick uh I'm not I I am very loathed to
short anyone when potentially we have a
long long time it's going to take
decades to turn America around in my
opinion but yes uh you know with all of
everything that's happened in boot gate
it just makes it seem like he is around
people who do not feel confident with
doing and so in response they're on an
attack mode and I think that's what
makes Trump in comparison even more
attractive to voters because through
everything he is ultimately the center
of the room this overconfident this
Brash guy he's not the most sve he's not
the most professional always but he acts
from a place of confidence and I think
that's what America's Americans really
crave right now in leadership thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 800m and become a
member over at
timcast.net next
time